was bedeutet das für eine kirche für
eine gemeinde wenn sie nicht mehr
zusammenkommen kann sonntagmorgen das
ist eigentlich die zeit wollte das
gemein gelungen beginnt im alltag unter
der woche ist das die zeit wo die leute
hier zusammengekommen
jeden sonntag treffen sie sich hier in
der kleinen pfarrkirche in washington dc
feiern gottesdienst trinken kaffee leben
umarmen sich
das geht jetzt alles nicht mehr seit
einigen tagen ist die tür zu
geschlossen wegen des corona virus das
ist sie die leere kirche für wer weiß
wie lange
wie schafft man das sich trotzdem nah
sein wenn man nicht hier nicht
beieinander sein darf pfarrerin ellen
hat einen plan
wir wollen jetzt online gottesdienste
machen
das habe ich noch nie zuvor gemacht wir
wollten schon seit jahren unsere technik
flottmachen war bislang war das noch nie
so nötig aber das ist es jetzt ab morgen
früh bin ich also online um 10 uhr 30
und versuche ganz alleine einen
virtuellen gottesdienst zu halten
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt ich weiß
nicht genau wie es laufen wird aber ich
freue mich auch darauf was ist etwas
neues und man muss kreativ werden
aber erstmal sich vertraut machen mit
der neuen technik
die frage ist seht ihr mich ja ich sehe
dich aber es wechsel zwischen dir und
einem telefon symbol alle mitglieder
junge und alte versuchen jetzt die
gemeinde zusammen zu halten
nur mal eine optische frage vor welchem
hintergrund soll ich denn sitzen im
kirchenraum wie immer
oder im gemeinderaum auf der couch was
schlag dir vor ich mag dein büro stimmt
mein büro gute idee ich habe ein
wirklich cooles büro kommt wir versuchen
will nachdem auch in den usa immer mehr
am corona virus erkranken war klar die
kirche muss schließen hygiene maßnahmen
reichen nicht das einzige was hilft
abstand zumindest aber einmal pro woche
zum gottesdienst soll es ein bisschen
sein wie immer das ist der bücher zimmer
so jetzt sich vor dem kamin kannst du
ein bisschen nach vorne rücken
[Gelächter]
ich musste lachen weil ihr echt toll
sein so ein feedback wollte ich am ende
gewinnt der gemeinschaftsraum
das ist vertraut wie bei unserer
kaffeerunde ich glaube was ich machen
werde ist zeige es euch mit dem finger
jetzt zeige ich in die richtige richtung
träumen die sachen von diesem tisch dort
weg und lassen nur das schwarze brett
und die bücher stehen eine kerze wäre
toll
ja sehr gut deshalb habe ich euch um
hilfe gefragt
ein bisschen normalität schaffen in
dieser ungewissen zeit die uns alle
verunsichert
wir reden immer darüber wie wichtig es
ist eine gemeinschaft zu sein und alle
einzubinden
es fühlt sich komisch an dass man nun
abstand halten müssen und dass etwas
gutes
deshalb soll sich meine predigt dich
noch nicht geschrieben habe
darum drehen und dann ist sonntag
eigentlich würde allen jetzt hier stehen
den raum voller menschen
heute ist das anders sie ist alleine
hier und gleichzeitig auch nicht denn
die gemeinde schaut im netz zu
willkommen und guten morgen zum ersten
online gottesdienst der klebenden park
gemeinde
wir sind eine offene gemeinde und wer
immer du bist und vor allem wo immer du
bist mitten im leben oder im netz du
bist hier herzlich willkommen
dann ist es doch ein bisschen so wie
[Musik]
und das virus das aktuell unseren alltag
bestimmt muss für einen moment draußen
bleiben
wir sind doch irgendwie zusammen egal ob
wir gerade zu hause bei unseren familien
sind oder eben alleine in der wohnung
mit unseren mitbewohnern oder mit
unserem partnerinnen und partnern in
dieser minute sind wir alle zusammen in
dieser virtuellen gemeinde und es ist
nicht nur eine virtuelle sondern eine
richtige gemeinde und für die ist allen
auch nach dem gottesdienst im einsatz
sie bringt älteren und kranken
lebensmittel vorbei
oder ein herbergseltern mit hat
gesundheitliche probleme als ich diese
woche einzelner gemeindemitglieder
angesprochen habe ob jemand etwas
braucht hat er mir eine spezielle liste
an dingen genannt für dir dankbar sie
ihre sehnsucht in ihrer gemeinde nach
möglichkeiten trotz des notwendigen
sozialen abstands füreinander da zu sein
und sich zu unterstützen
hallo
oh mein gott diesen schön bedankt sich
mit blumen
ich melde mich bei dir aber auch andere
gemeindemitglieder werden dich anrufen
ich schreibe werke allens gemeinde hat
sich organisiert angepasst nur kurze
zeit nachdem das virus sich in unserem
alltag breit gemacht hat und trotzdem
kann sie es kaum erwarten wenn wir nicht
mehr auf distanz gehen müssen